keeping personas in mind when you're
designing a product how does
accessibility play into personas like
with all personas you want those to be
based on information from talking to
real users and so again it's no
different here and so you want to go out
and actually talk with people that have
these impairments and when you're
developing your persona some key pieces
of information that you want to include
are what is their impairment what is the
severity of it how do they kind of
tackle and channel get through their
daily challenges with the impairment
what are certain assistive technologies
that they use what or how experienced
are they with those assistive
technologies what's their skill level
you want to talk about what are their
pain points and trying to achieve tasks
that are related to your your product
the whole goal is just to really try to
get in some important insights into how
they go about completing tasks and what
are some of their different approaches
that they might take that may be your
other users that you've already spoken
to haven't and what if I don't have
access necessarily to someone who has an
impairment like who else could I contact
our how might I get that insight well
you'd be surprised at because there is a
wide range of impairments like again if
somebody that has just kind of lower
vision versus somebody that's completely
blind you probably do know somebody with
some sort of impairment and just just
thinking about an older relative maybe
that has lost a bit of their vision or
has arthritis and their level of
dexterity isn't as what it used to be
that's really valuable insights that you
can talk to them about or somebody who's
not a native speaker of the language
that's prominent in your app they have
to kind of approach things in a
different way - that could be really
insightful so there's a lot of there's a
lot of people out there that you might
not immediately consider talking to that
would be really
valuable great what companies have you
seen that have been designing for all
users and especially with those with
impairments so stepping out of the
digital world for a minute I think two
great examples are the Bradley watch
which is right here the Bradley watch
was designed from the get-go of thinking
about people with impairments always
with visual impairments in particular
and so what this watch allows you to do
is tell time with just feeling the watch
and you can see there's there's two
magnetic balls here that indicate the
hour in the minute and this is obviously
great for people with disabilities in
that it helps them tell the time but it
also is visually appealing it's very
aesthetically pleasing and it doesn't
look like anything very different than
other watches so it doesn't draw
attention to their disability which is
always an added bonus to to these types
of devices but then just thinking about
in situations where if you are sighted
you might be in a dark movie theater or
in a meeting or a discussion where you
don't want to take your gaze away and
you want to still understand what time
it is it's really valuable yeah so you
can see this is like a great example of
thinking about those needs up front and
coming up with a great product for
everybody and the other one was access
yes and so oXXO design is that they have
a whole design team that focus on
universal design which we talked about
before and some of their products always
have are always keeping in mind
different different needs and so some
examples are they they talk about this
again on their website where they can
use a salad spinner with one hand or
their measuring cups are really unique
in that you don't have to kind of bend
down to see where the where the water
the liquid is measuring you can look
over and see where the numbers are so
they take a lot of things into
consideration again and it benefits all
users not just those with disabilities
service and to wrap up what are your
final thoughts on accessibility I would
like to say that yes it can be daunting
it can be time-consuming if it's left
till the end of the design development
process there's always a lot of
retrofitting and rethinking that needs
to happen if it's left to the end
there's no doubt about it
so to save everyone time and pain think
about it early
think about it throughout the entire
process and just incorporate it into
your existing process and in the end not
only will you have saved time but you
will also come up with a much better
product that's usable for everybody